florent pagny
on bannit 16 albums studio 4 albums live
15 millions de disques vendus
37 cobra transformer en blouson douce
crocodiles transformer en pantalon 32
les a transformés en chaussures gens
remaniées maison
c'est des scientifiques américains ont
découvert qu'en moyenne navigator avait
une chance sur dix de finir en pantalon
de florent pagny
et les fid
américaine l'émission s'appelle salut
les terriens et le groupe les crémants
de fortune
mais
et maintenant mon stagiaire comme villa
la liberté de penser
vous êtes libres ici tonnes heureusement
que philippe d'ailleurs parce que je
suis stagiaire je dis ce que je veux je
risque quoi comme retiens mes tickets
resto j'en ai même pas ouais je n'aurai
pas ma liberté de pensée thiriet moi par
contre je sais pas qui chante cette
chanson mais
tu dis c'est l'autre con d'obispo ou
quoi
bon en tout cas ce soir thierry on a un
plateau de jeunes il a tout ce soir et
là on n'a pas à rougir face aux
américains florent pagny jude law et
diam's
florent pagny c'est à moi mon sort du
lot j'adore florent pagny parce que
c'est l'homme qui chante ce qu'ils
pensent voilà un problème avec la presse
il chante presse qui coule me casse les
couilles à problèmes avec le fisc ah non
ça va voi avec le fisc ma liberté de
penser bon on espère juste que vous
aurez pas de problèmes d'érection ça
c'est le
en tout cas thierry ou là les différents
pagny c'est aussi une gueule et un look
alors après tout les les coupes et
nature que vous avez fait vous avez
encore tous vos cheveux florence est
quand même incroyable alors je te donne
le tuyau j'ai fait des implants c'est
vrai ça tu arriveras aussi
aussi
attention parce que c'est extrêmement
bien que la priorité sera bientôt la c1
annoncé laisser la technique se veut par
cheveux et ça marche très bien en tout
cas florent vous avez dit j'ai toujours
habitué les gens ne pas être coiffés de
la même manière tout cas c'est con parce
que le fisc vous reconnaît toujours
les piments balle le style de florent
raoul a dit thierry voilà c'est que bon
je sais pas qui est le styliste de
florence ça doit être le zoo de beauval
non mais c'est vrai nom mais florent
quand il regarde un documentaire sur
planète et l'impression de regarder les
rênes du shopping voilà mon dressing
écoles danoise olélé cocody il l'appelle
papa donc barrette on arrête on n'arrête
pas mais l'histoire nous
[Applaudissements]
aurons d'ici la semaine prochaine est en
tournée dans toute la france
il triomphe tous les samedis dans de
voice il a vendu plus de huit cent mille
exemplaires de son dernier album il en
sort un nouveau il est au top c'est
florent pagny
[Applaudissements]
jean banni re bonsoir bonsoir florent
une rumeur insistante cours à votre
sujet une rumeur étonnante qu'on ne
retrouverait pas votre nombre mais
panama papers aucune société offshore
pour échapper aux impôts [ __ ] florent
non je
dirais trop fort
échappé belle qu'est ce qui se passe je
suis notre héros bah je le suis toujours
moi j'espère oui parce que je paye de
plus en plus
alors je vous dis quand même vous posez
la question que tout le monde se pose
est ce qu'il ya un moyen de payer moins
d'impôts sans se faire chier à lui des
vaches en patagonie
alors en fait
oui
il faut être résident américain voilà
parce que les américains ils demandent à
avoir tous ouais la france et
l'argentine en argentine du fait que
perdre et en fait ça compense le ce que
tu gagnes en france à essay équilibre en
amérique où je n'ai rien foutu peine 28
pour cent en cinq mois est ce qui
devrait être un impôt normal on a
romancé suggéré argentine c'est 35 aussi
sauf chez nous mais bon ils vont y
arriver à un moment donné tu sais et à
vouloir toujours taxer plus pour gagner
plus et se rendre compte que c'est moins
peut-être qu'un jour il ya un chevreuil
d'heure qui arrivera je reversais qu'il
ira et si on taxe et moins et légendes à
celui qu'on sera bien sûr tu descends
les charges patronales des charges
salariales est embauchent plus télé m
[Applaudissements]
non non non moi libre les toits sont
depuis jérôme cahuzac et thomas
thévenoud j'imagine qu'on vous fait
moins chier avec l'histoire d'impôts non
enfin en même temps ils suivent au
quotidien tout ce que j'ai si jamais il
y avait une possibilité mais ça c'est
juste je leur laisserai jamais c'est la
période des déclarations d'impôts c'est
pour cette compagnie là aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et en tous les cas au nom de toutes les
écoles tous les hôpitaux de toutes les
routes merci florentaise
un million par an ça fait dix écoles
alors pour payer vos impôts vous avez un
moyen qui est très bon c'est que la
moitié de vos impôts en france sont
payés par the voice cinq cent mille
euros on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
cette année un maximum de talent quand
alice et dans le jury va falloir qu'on
soit sobre et très concentré dans un
univers tu payes ta voix quelle
prestance hier que cloud où il est mais
j'ai vu nul au barca
moi je suis la petite nouveau je suis
tellement fier dans le jury de the voice
je compte rester humble dans un univers
méthyle nul je vais t'expliquer en
quatre chapitres et 18 sous partie
pourquoi tu ne peux pas être le voir on
dit la voix pas le voir il est con ce
libanais on va on s'entend bien dans le
gérer un srec on s'adore artistiquement
et puis une bonne ambiance pas de
rivalité entre tous des potes cette
année y'a plein d'univers il ya beaucoup
de talents qui moi je la m plaindre robe
avec très peu de tissu je vais changer
de vernis ya plein de chaussures où tu
as vraiment ta place dans cette émission
parce que tu m'as tu m'a touché tu as
vraiment un univers à toi mais en fait
moi je suis technicien change le micro
vous
alors le nouvel album s'appelle habana
miami cuba l'argentine
assurément ne s'est pas lancé dans
trafic de drogue je sais pas parce que
c'est un truc de pablo azcona
c'était une console n'est pas de la
drogue donc l'idée de la banane qui est
venue quand barack obama annoncé la
levée de l'embargo sur cuba
mais bon en même temps il ya 60 ans tout
s'est arrêté depuis 60 ans le 27 à
reggio mobile il ya une pâte une patine
alors moi j'adore les vieilles bagnoles
y'a que ça j'adore la vieille
architecture avec la patine et tout
c'est que ça que j allais et ses
sublimes j'espère que ça sera pas
détruit trop rapidement moi j'espère
aussi bon bouygues est déjà arrivé en
nettoyant un peu du quartier pour monter
ce officier d'artillerie lourde et de
garder les faces a et oui vous
connaissez la casa della musica a essayé
- bienne on
voit du rhum et on saute en l'air je
vais bientôt me voyais alors ce rhum
c'est quelque chose l'europe doit
alors je vais quitter miami pourrait ya
plus d'indicateurs pour vous habille
non miami c'était vraiment ainsi un lieu
de passage c'est un lieu de transit
c'est un lieu de vacances or à part ça
faisait toujours 4000 têtes de bétail en
patagonie vous croyez qu'elle qu'elle
nous regardent ce soir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu